donc qu'est ce que sont les ogm est ce
que vous savez à peu près pareil
une courte définition de ce que peuvent
être un ogm au fait comment vous
essaieriez de définir sa non vous n'êtes
pas à la faculté de biologie mais bien à
l'école d'art de belfort
ce matin la petite remise à niveau sur
les organismes génétiquement modifiés de
la théorie mais aussi de la pratique
pour sa direction les remparts fortifiée
située juste derrière l'école ça c'est
vous ras le groupe est à bois encore un
truc aux lentilles pour quelques heures
ces élèves délaissent leurs pinceaux
pour empoigner d'autres outils en ce
début de printemps ils doivent préparer
la terre ait commencé leurs premières
plantations
du coup ça nous impacte niveau écologie
on apprend comment planter
on apprend à faire rien que de la
lessive avec de la sente ce genre de
choses c'est intéressant pour nous
autant économiquement que que
d'apprendre
voilà sur la nature c'est toujours
intéressant une à deux fois par semaine
tous s'initient à leur rythme aux
rudiments du jardinage et de la
botanique
c'est juste l'occasion de mettre un peu
les mains dans la terre c'est pas
forcément quelque chose qu'on a tous
l'habitude de faire c'est aussi d'une
ouverture et ça peut nous et aussi nos
travaux finalement on a plusieurs
personnes qui ont fait des travaux qui
seront finalement une part ou d'autre se
rapporte au jardin ou à la nature au
végétal et en fait ça ça ouvre vachement
sur cette parcelle mise à disposition
par la ville
un jardin suspendu est en train de voir
le jour
c'est la première fois qu'une école
d'art propose un tel atelier grandeur
nature pour pauline gillard qui porte le
projet l'objectif est double
sensibiliser à la biodiversité et faire
germer une autre approche de la cd
futurs artistes des futurs créateurs
sait aussi que cette relation en vivant
un flux leur travail artistique le
nourrissent et que ce soit aussi un
facteur d'inspiration et de construction
sa démarche artistique au même titre que
des pinceaux que de là que de la
peinture que le vivant est une part de
leurs inspirations quoi à terme un
système d'irrigation et des ruches
devrait aussi être installé un projet
innovant qui a reçu le soutien de la
fondation de france
40000 euros sur trois ans pour
développer la démarche
une démarche qui pourrait être étendue à
d'autres écoles d'art un peu partout
dans l'hexagone